les niortais en bleu ont du mal débuté
leur rencontre en prenant un but dans le
premier quart d'heure ils sont
actuellement 13e au classement de ligue
2 et pour rattraper les 13 points qui
les séparent de metz le leader les
chamois comptent sur leur attaquant il
s'appelle emiliano sala c'est le
portrait sport de ce dimanche
prêté par bordeaux l'argentin espère
confirmer son potentiel cette saison
avec niort en ligue 2 pour évoluer l'an
prochain en ligue 1 sous le maillot des
girondins freddy veto julien delage
l'ont rencontré la semaine dernière dans
les deux sèvres
regardez
ces buts lui font découvrir la france à
23 ans emiliano sala poursuit son tour
de l'hexagone
arrivé aux girondins de bordeaux il y a
trois ans prêté à orléans l'an passé
l'attaquant argentin découvre
aujourd'hui la cité niortaise
terme il que mesplès mille tranquille
chemière fait de temps en temps quand
des choletais lui je viens sur la place
en centre-ville pour fermer la valve
avait un petit peu sa présence en deux
sèvres
emiliano sala la doit à ses performances
l'an passé en national sous les couleurs
orléanaise l'attaquant inscrit 18 buts
et attire les convoitises des clubs de
ligue 2 metz nancy sont sur les rangs
mais seniors et son manager karim fradin
qui se montrent les plus convaincants et
sont aujourd'hui convaincus qu'ils nous
ont marqués entre 12 et 15 bus en tout
cas ce qu'on espère pour lui et pour
nous mais en tout cas en termes d'état
d'esprit
c'est un charmant garçon qui fait pas de
vagues et qui est toujours motivé dans
le travail
donc c'est un gros recrutement parfait
après on verra au mois de mai pour faire
le bilan mais en tout cas où
jusqu'ici on est très content de son
arrivée après 15 matches de championnat
emiliano sala totalise 6 buts à la
pointe de l'attaqué il ne ménage pas ses
efforts se créent de nombreuses
occasions
toutes ne sont pas convertis son style
lui coûte parfois un peu de lucidité
je suis un attaquant atypique comme ça
combatif donc c'est mon jeu et après
j'aime bien le club
on joue bien au ballon au chaud au sol
et après bon travail pour marquer des
buts et etc a pu arriver maintenant ça
commence et ça fait du bien
titulaire indiscutable l'argentin a
aussi su en quelques mois se faire une
place dans le vestiaire niortais fidèle
à lui même en toute discrétion sa super
départ et un petit mil dont elle se
lâche un peu plus et non moi je
m'entends très bien avec lui
prêté pour un an sans option d'achat
emiliano sala quittera les deux sèvres
en fin de saison mais de son parcours à
niort dépend son avenir à bordeaux
s'il concrétise les espoirs placés en
lui l'argentin portera l'an prochain le
maillot des girondins en ligue 1
[Musique]